♪ ♪
>> Laura: ON THE FLU VACCINES
IN MASSACHUSETTS, THEY ARE
MANDATING THAT CHILDREN GET FLU
VACCINES IN ORDER TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
THERE’S A CONTROVERSY ABOUT
THAT, A LOT OF PARENTS ARE LIKE
WE DON’T WANT OUR KIDS TO GET
THE FLU VACCINE BURIED ARE YOU
WORRIED THAT ON THE PUSH FOR
VACCINES, THESE FAST VACCINES
FOR COVID, YOU MIGHT BE
SPLITTING A COALITION OF
AMERICAN FRANKLY IN BOTH PARTIES
WHO AREN’T COMFORTABLE?
>> President Trump: ONCE YOU
GET TO A CERTAIN NUMBER -- WE
USE THE WORD "HERD"."
ONCE YOU GET TO A CERTAIN NUMBER
IT’S GOING TO GO AWAY, SO IT
DOESN’T HAVE TO BE, BUT YEAH, I
MEAN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO WANT TO DO IT.
>> Laura: SHOULD IT BE
MANDATORY?
>> President Trump: I NEVER
HAD THE FLU BUT I NEVER HAD A
SHOT.
I NEVER HAD A VACCINE.
I COME THE FIRST DAY -- SIR, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A FLU SHOT.
I SAID WHY?
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT.
I SAY WHAT’S THE PERCENTAGE?
I WASN’T THRILLED WITH THE
PERCENTAGE.
IT’S LIKE 50%.
>> Laura: DR. FAUCI SAID IT
MIGHT NOT GIVE "GREAT
PROTECTION" BECAUSE IT’S A
CORONAVIRUS.
>> President Trump: I SAID IF
I’VE NEVER HAD IT, WOULDN’T IT
BE GOOD TO?
AND THEN I THOUGHT I SHOULD HAVE
IT -- I’VE HAD IT NOW THREE
TIMES.
AND I STILL HAVEN’T HAD THE FLU.
SO MAYBE I WILL GIVE CREDIT TO
THE FLU VACCINE.
I DON’T KNOW.
I WILL SAY THIS.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
VACCINE VERY SOON.
A LOT OF TREMENDOUS WORK HAS
BEEN DONE.
A VACCINE JUST LIKE WE HAVE
THERAPEUTICS, WHICH TO ME ARE
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
YOU GOING TO THE HOSPITAL TO
MAKE PEOPLE BETTER.
THAT’S TO ME, THE MOST -- AND WE
JUST DID THE CONVALESCENT
PLASMA.
I THINK -- AND YOU HAVE OTHER
THINGS TOO SO I THINK WE WILL
HAVE A LOT OF THERAPEUTICS WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A VACCINE VERY
SOON.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE TAKE
IT --
>> Laura: 35% SAY THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO TAKE THE COVID VACCINE.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE MANDATORY.
>> President Trump: TO THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD IT AT ALL
THE OTHER THINGS, PEOPLE THAT
HAVE HAD IT WHERE IN THEORY YOU
CAN’T GET IT, ONE PERSON AND
THEY ARE MAKING A BIG DEAL.
ONE PERSON GOT IT TWICE, BUT IF
YOU ATE IT ALL UP IT GIVES A
VERY GOOD PROTECTION.
>> Laura: BIDEN SAID HE WOULD
CHECK ON THE ECONOMY AGAIN IF
THE SCIENTISTS SAID THAT WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST COVID.
WOULD YOU?
>> President Trump: I THINK
IT’S A VERY DANGEROUS STATEMENT
FOR HIM TO MAKE.
WE DID THE RIGHT THING.
WE SHUT IT DOWN AND WE BUILT IT
UP AND WE ARE SETTING RECORDS
AND JOB NUMBERS, RECORDS AND
RETAIL NUMBERS, SO THIS GUY
COMES IN.
I HEARD AT THE OTHER DAY.
THAT MEANS THAT IF SOME DOCTOR
SAID WE HAVE TO SHUT IT DOWN, WE
ARE GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN.
WE ARE SETTING RECORDS.
BY THE WAY, THE STOCK MARKET IS
AT AN ALL-TIME RECORD RIGHT NOW.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON IN
THE STOCK MARKET, LOOK AT WHAT’S
GOING ON.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
PHENOMENAL YEAR NEXT YEAR, WE
WILL HAVE A GREAT THIRD QUARTER.
INTERESTINGLY, THE NUMBERS FOR
THE THIRD QUARTER WILL COME OUT
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU WORRIED IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS IN THE
MARKET -- TRUMPETS PUSHING THE
MARKET?
>> President Trump: I CAN TELL
YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING.
NANCY PELOSI DOESN’T WANT TO
GIVE ANY STIMULUS.
WE SHOULD HAVE IT, IT WASN’T THE
PEOPLE’S FAULT THAT CHINA GIVE
US THE VIRUS.
WHETHER IT WAS THROUGH --
>> Laura: THEY THEY CALLED A
DOMESTIC ENEMY, ENEMY OF THE
STATE.
HOW DO YOU WORK WITH HER ON
ANOTHER STIMULUS?
>> President Trump: I ALWAYS
TELL HER TO GO BACK TO
SAN FRANCISCO, TAKE CARE OF YOUR
HOMELESS PROBLEM, TAKE CARE OF
YOUR PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IT’S NOTHING LIKE WHAT
I’M WITNESSING OUT THERE, RIGHT
OUTSIDE, RIGHT WHERE SHE LIVES,
RIGHT IN HER DISTRICT IS SO BAD.
>> Laura: STIMULUS ARE NOT?
>> President Trump: WOULD LIKE
TO GET IT FOR THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
IT WASN’T THEIR FAULT BUT SHE
DOESN’T WANT TO GET IT BECAUSE
THAT WILL MAKE THE ECONOMY A
LITTLE BIT BETTER AND THAT WILL
BE A TERRIBLE THING.
>> Laura: IF YOU HAVE TO DO IT
ALL AGAIN -- I KNOW IT’S KIND OF
A HARD QUESTION, BUT DO IT ALL
AGAIN, WOULD YOU PUT FAUCI FRONT
AND CENTER EVERY DAY IN CHARGE
OF THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE?
>> President Trump: I GET
ALONG WITH THEM VERY WELL, I
DISAGREE WITH HIM, A LOT OF WHAT
HE SAID.
KEEP IT OPEN FOR CHINA AND HE
ADMITS IT.
I GET ALONG WITH THEM, BUT EVERY
ONCE IN A WHILE HE WILL COME UP
WITH ONE THAT I SAY WHERE DID
THAT COME FROM?
I INHERITED HIM, HE WAS HERE, HE
WAS A PART OF THIS HUGE PIECE OF
MACHINERY -- I DIDN’T PUT
ANYBODY IN CHARGE.
HE WAS HERE.
HE’S BEEN HERE FOR 40 YEARS.
>> Laura: ’84.
1984.
>> President Trump: HE’S BEEN
HERE FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
YOU INHERIT A LOT OF PEOPLE,
IT’S PART OF THE MACHINERY AND
YOU HAVE SOME YOU LOVE, SOME YOU
DON’T.
I LIKE HIM, I DON’T AGREE WITH
HIM THAT OFTEN, BUT I LIKE HIM.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU LOOK BACK
ON THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN THE
FIRST THREE WERE IMPEACHMENT,
MUELLER, PANDEMIC,
INVESTIGATIONS, WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
WHAT THEY DON’T SEE WHEN THEY’RE
DOING INTERVIEWS LIKE THIS?
HOW YOU COPE WITH THIS CONSTANT
BARRAGE FROM THE HILL?
IS ALWAYS BACK AND FORTH, THAT’S
FINE, BUT IT’S BEEN DIFFERENT
FOR YOU.
>> President Trump: IT’S BEEN
DIFFERENT BECAUSE I’VE
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH.
ON THE MILITARY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED -- FIRST OF ALL,
BRINGING MANY OF THE TROOPS
HOME, EVEN CUTTING DOWN GERMANY,
OKAY, BECAUSE THEY’VE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF US LIKE YOU
WOULDN’T BELIEVE.
IT’S BEEN DIFFERENT FOR A LOT OF